you wasted time on this it is a little
bit frustrating if it makes you feel any
better
i also wasted some time on it um but at
least we've wasted time together so
it's um a bunch of products do you
remember that
uh and and
what was the reading of speech
okay so um and if it does fall out quite
quickly actually
because it was the right answer um what
do we do again
simple let's just go through the
missions for the beginning let's test it
okay uh what's the first value that i
can stick in there
it's just one right which means that
it's just this part here
one times two which is
two all right right hand side
is one over three times one plus one
plus two that's three over three times
two
okay um we can assume it
i'm not gonna waste pace up here because
i think you know when it's gonna look
like it's just going to look like that
with k's that's all but when i get to
the next step
this is where the algebraic fun ensues
okay again write your left hand side in
a way that makes it easier for you to
do this substitution by assumption okay
so
i'm required to prove
one by two plus two by three
and so on and rather than skipping to
the very last term i'm going to include
the second last one as well
okay k plus one one last tabby
k plus one k plus two yeah good
um so easy to go into autopilot and just
make numerical areas here
all right what do we got on the right
hand side k plus one
on three and the front
this will become k plus two and that'll
be k plus three
okay so off we go we'll start with the
left hand side
and here's our inductive set okay so my
assumption again i'll get my color out
these are the parts all the way up to
here
that i can substitute and i'm
substituting for this
with k's instead of ends right so k on
three
k plus one
plus this bit on the end which wasn't
included in the
assumption okay
uh again just to emphasize please
include that please
put some like big flashing lights around
it so you don't forget to say it
um it's one of those annoying bits and
mats where saying it doesn't get any
marks
but not having it we'll lose your marks
which is frustrating i know but
it's a little thing and it's not like
it's long you have to write so off we go
now
uh if i want to get to here and this is
what i got
okay you can see the bits that are
already in the right spot i've got my
k plus two here and here i've got my k
plus one here and here
and those bits look good right and then
all that's left is the k plus three on
the end
which doesn't appear here yet anyway
okay
so what am i going to have to do let's
try and get this on a common denominator
because i've got
two terms here and one fraction over
there so this really doesn't require all
that much rearrangement does it
um i've got k lots on
three k plus one
k plus two all i have to do here to get
on the same denominator is the
denominator is three right so multiply
by three
okay you can see i can combine those
into one fraction all over three
which is the one that comes out the
front here's my k plus one
there's my k plus two and my k plus
three
comes from the coefficients k
plus three that's it
can't believe i wasted half an hour on
this dark question okay so
uh let's get in the right order okay
first one
actually it's one of the simple ones
sorry so
again from there that's equal to my
right hand side and then you make your
explanation
it's um by the principle of mathematical
induction
it's true for sorry that's atrocious
okay what's up now by the way
um why do i write this when you guys
actually quite good at and
you know i we can all read set notation
the reason why
i tend to avoid this is because i went
what i said before when you've got a
different case
okay like say it's values four and up so
before five six and so on
if you write this a lot at least this is
what i did
you just sort of get into autopilot for
writing the same thing every time and
you don't pay attention
to what values they are right so that's
why when you write this
as you start to write it if you've got
it wrong like if it was meant to be
five six as you write one two three
you'll be like oh hold on and then you
think back you can look back on the same
page
you can see you didn't start at one you
start at four or whatever value okay
whereas when you do this you don't pick
up the error so quickly okay it's not as
automatic so that's one of the reasons
why even though it's
longer i'll write that down